bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte la
crise de lakovic 19 expose les failles
de la mondialisation
on l'a vu avec l'approvisionnement des
masques on s'est rendu compte qu'on
était dépendant des pays qui fabriquent
ces produits
mais qu'en est il des denrées
alimentaires se nourrir c'est un besoin
essentiel alors le canada est-il
autosuffisant sur le plan alimentaire ou
et il l'a aussi vulnérable on se demande
pourquoi personne ne réalise et ce avant
en terme d'autonomie alimentaire pour
mousser la base visée
c'est un besoin de base au même titre
que seloger puis au même titre que
d'être en sécurité
il ya une grosse grosse grosse demande
pour les produits du québec le tout à
fait il ferait aussi la maman de vide
trop loin de chez moi
alors c'est quoi le futur avec son vaste
territoire et son abondante
le canada est très bien anti quand vient
le temps de nourrir sa population
on compte ici 1,2 hectare de terres
arables par habitant c'est six fois plus
que la france
treize fois plus que la chine a priori
il n'y a donc aucun souci à avoir on va
faire évidemment d'entrevue particulière
aujourd'hui pascal thériault est
agroéconomiste atteint de lakovic 19
il est confiné chez lui le canada est
plus tard personne n'ignore d'aliments
sur la planète le canada offre du bouc
plus belles humain qu'il va y voit en
consommer
le pays se démarque dans plusieurs
secteurs 70% du porc produit ici est
exportée 75% du blé 95% des légumineuses
et un système qui survit uniquement au
canada
la gestion de l'offre 46
l'approvisionnement de denrées de base
on dit qu'on va avoir les deux
voilà deux qui vont être produits aux
canadiens plus consommés ce qu'une bombe
dans ces secteurs il n'y a pratiquement
pas d'importation ni d'exportation
l'offre est arrimée à la demande
canadienne
mais si nous sommes des champions de la
production de céréales et de viande
entre autres il existe tout de même un
secteur qui n'arrive pas à combler nos
besoins
pourtant ce sont exactement ces aliments
que le nouveau guide alimentaire
canadien nous recommandent de manger le
plus selon les nutritionnistes la moitié
de notre assiette devrait être composé
de fruits et légumes
ces aliments représentent seulement 11%
la nourriture produite au canada ce qui
équivaut environ 2 portions de fruits et
légumes par canadiens par jour
evans fraser est un spécialiste de la
sécurité alimentaire
il constate que depuis vingt ans le
canada a perdu des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares de cultures maraîchères bien
et fermiers en ontario et un peu partout
au canada ont réduit leur superficie de
fruits et légumes et se sont tournés
vers des cultures plus rentables comme
le maïs et le soya et de canola
des productions maraîchères sont allés
vers la grande culture parce que bon
peut-être plus fragile a besoin de moins
de main d'oeuvre de moyens main puis bon
on peut quand même et porte une offre
hinault légumes et non pays
donc sur le long terme de ce qui s'est
passé qui fait effet post tellement vrai
prénom élection serrée pour plein
d'autres produits la france et que la
nourriture on note deux ans à conduire
cultiver du maïs et du soya s'inscrit
aussi dans la volonté de faire une
agriculture basée sur l'exportation
ces plantes servent de nourriture pour
les ports entre autres qui sont
majoritairement destinés aux marchés
étrangers
professeur à la faculté d'agriculture de
l'université laval
patrick mendler réfléchit depuis
longtemps à ces questions au québec
aujourd'hui sur on a à peu près un
million d'hectares semer en oléagineux
et serré et céréales j'encule maïs et le
soya là dedans ma 80% de ses productions
lave sondés sont à destination de la de
l'alimentation animale
et puis une partie quand même
significatif de notre maïs sert aussi à
fabriquer de l'éthanol
au québec près de 12 % du maïs et
transformés en éthanol en ontario c'est
plus de 30% selon les dernières données
disponibles le canada et le quatrième
importateur de légumes au monde et cette
année les grands producteurs maraîchers
d'ici s'attendent à devoir réduire leur
production
nous sommes au début avril sur la terre
de dennis van winden un tracteur
s'élance pour la première fois de
l'année de 8 avril c'est un peu tôt mais
on va essayer on va naître entre des
petites carottes qu'on pourrait
possiblement récoltés dans les alentours
du 15 au 20 juillet
ces belles terres noires extrêmement
fertiles sont le jardin potager du
québec
paradoxalement en été on arrive à
produire beaucoup de légumes et même à
en exporter le reste de l'année
c'est une autre histoire à la ferme des
vanneaux in den le produit vedette et la
laitue elle se retrouve au menu deux
grandes chaînes de restauration rapide
sur la côte est américaine mais avec la
fermeture des restaurants au sud de la
frontière
le maraîcher doit rapidement faire des
choix quel légume répondra le mieux à la
demande du marché actuel un véritable
casse tête logistique
chiche le ti vct tout en carotte demain
matin je suppose que je vois les notes
ni carotte à l'automne où les entreposer
pour les garder pour la saison la saison
froide alors on est physiquement on a
des contraintes et aussi sans compter
que les connaissances actuelles ne
permettent pas de conserver ce légume
racine toute l'année à compter du
printemps
nous dépendons des importations
cet ancien continent mais ce qui donne
le plus de monde et ces jours ci aux
producteurs ce sont ces travailleurs
mexicains ou plutôt leur absence
quinze travailleurs sont arrivés mais le
nid van winden
on embauche normalement près de 50
dans la production de lexus et une
production qui est très très manuelle
alors la plantation au sein le
désherbage la récolte on va travailler
avec 25 30 35 personnes en avant de nous
récoltons alors si j'ai pas de
travailleurs cette année pour récolter 7
l'étude à mon point d'interrogation et
je vais faire quoi et comment
cette crise met en lumière la dangereuse
dépendance du secteur agricole envers
les travailleurs étrangers temporaires
ils sont 55 milles dans les fermes
canadiennes chaque année plus de 14
mille au québec
il faut penser que la terre
contrairement à une usine qui fabrique
des masques ou des blues vous pouvez pas
délocaliser vos ha vous pouvez pas aller
à la manoeuvre c'est l'amateur qui via
ou voilà est alors effectivement dans ce
genre de situation ma la fragilité de
cette autorisation
apparaît de façon plus crue selon dennis
van winden
la technologie sera la clé pour
améliorer notre autosuffisance
collective
il lance d'ailleurs un cri du coeur ou
chercheurs et aux ingénieurs avec la
vision aujourd'hui avec la robotisation
que ces choses là je suis ce jeu que
c'est un viol serait très intéressé à
avoir des projets pour commencer à
réinventer des machineries qui nous a
aidés beaucoup alors on a besoin des
recherches aussi pour savoir quand même
conserver nos carottes plus longtemps
comment conserver nos jeunes y ont plus
longtemps que j'étais resteront alors
c'est un peu cette cette autonomie la
con con con des merlettes qu'on
recherche pour augmenter notre
autosuffisance emprise et légumes
une solution serait la culture en serre
même pendant la saison froide à
l'ange-gardien en outaouais
françois biron est l'un des rares
producteurs maraîchers à faire pousser
des légumes en plein hiver
comme je peux pas inventer de légumes je
peux pas me différencier ce niveau là la
seule chose que je peux faire de
différent des autres c'est d'avoir des
légumes quand les autres en ont pas tout
ce que permet les serres froides puis à
fur et à mesure d'expérimentation s'est
rendu compte qu'on est capable d'étirer
des tirs et détruira saison pratiquement
jusqu'à la joindre de l'automne jusqu'au
printemps
ces épinards sont qu'elle et autres
légumes feuilles pousse dans des serres
qui ne sont pas chauffées ont choisi ces
cultures principalement pour leur
tolérance au froid donc comme une
condition très froide très peu de
luminosité
on se concentre sur des légumes qui
poussent bien dans ces conditions là
un système de badge permet de conserver
la chaleur du jour est d'éviter que le
mercure ne chuteront pendant la nuit ont
fait briller dans une serre sous
plastique avec la luminosité qu'on a on
peut atteindre des températures de 20 à
25 degrés celsius
même si fait - 10 10 - 20 à l'extérieur
hors saison si on ne veut pas se limiter
aux légumes racines de nos grands
parents
il faudra selon lui une plus grande
ouverture nous les producteurs on est
capable de faire un bout en termes de
production parce qu'il ya certains
légumes qu'on est capables qui pousse
bien durant l'hiver mais aussi du point
de vue du consommateur qui lui aussi
doit faire son petit bout de chemin doit
s'ouvrir aux niveaux les guillaume
lamarche les mêlées moutarde et bolchoï
et cetera donc c'est du donnant donnant
mais l'auto suffisance est encore loin à
peine le tiers des légumes de serre
consommés au québec ont poussé dans la
province
une situation qui pourrait cependant
changer si on en croit les plus hautes
instances politiques
si elles ne sont qu on tire de la crise
actuelle c'est qu'on devrait être
autonome pour les pieds qui sont
essentiels
crise qui ébranle bien des certitudes
propulsé l'agriculture en l'avant scène
comme jamais auparavant
donc on veut être capable entre au tac
est simple le fait qu'on ait un coût des
lectrices ticket trebor ben d'être
capable de produire davantage le calme
un put être autonome est ce que cette
filière là va se développer au québec
mais si la filière se développe au
québec on wye klopp ont alimenté en
électricité
on a des capacités pour être capable
d'une femme depuis des années les
producteurs en serre du québec réclame
que les ressources colossales de la
province en hydroélectricité puisse être
transformée en fruits et légumes le
québec à québec on a la place et on
aurait la carrure davantage en panne
manger une pomme là à produire et le
problème majeur c'est l'accès à un tarif
préférentiel comme celui accordé aux
alumineries et à d'autres grandes
industries s'il y avait droit
les producteurs en serre estime qu'il
pourrait doubler la production
enfin qu' on va faire des choix est ce
que les producteurs d'avoir accès propre
fiable pour toi produits au québec
moi je crois qu we are que nous devons
avoir avec la percu nourris et tous les
experts s'entendent pour assurer une
meilleure résilience de notre système
agroalimentaire
il est primordial que les petites fermes
trouvent leur place aux côtés des plus
grandes
à saint pie près de saint-hyacinthe cinq
jeunes maraîchers ont transformé la
grande course derrière leurs duplex et
une autre parcelle on potager hautement
productifs faire de l'agriculture
intense et puis ce qui veut dire que sur
des toutes petites loges on peut sortir
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de rendement
parce qu'on a pas une machinerie
agricole d'enfance qu'on ne céda
machinerie manuel fait qu'on a pas de
tracteur qui doivent passer dans les
champs
60 paniers de légumes qui ont déjà tous
trouvé preneurs leur permet d'écouler
leur production et pour augmenter
l'offre de la ferme
les 16 poules pondeuses aurons bientôt
des renforts qu'on allait augmenter
probablement 30-40 poules pondeuses
pourquoi avoir des douzaines de de façon
quotidienne organisé en co-op les
maraîchers presque tous issus de la même
famille voudrait que leur ferme traîne
de l'expansion et nourrissent encore
plus de gens mais le territoire a beau
être immense au québec y accéder n'est
pas toujours facile nous en tant que
petite production maraîchère ce qu'on
cherche en 31 7 8 hectares mais 7 8 ha
ici en montérégie ça existe plus qui
même dans d'autres régions c'est
difficile à trouver aussi du 7 8
hectares
l'accès difficile encore une fois parce
que le prix de l'hectare et cher parce
qu'il est difficile de morceler des
terres pour un peu pour acheter juste le
petit lot et puis aussi sans doute parce
qu'il ya une concurrence faite par des
personnes qui n'ont pas forcément
l'intention de faire de l'agriculture
mais qui souhaitent s'installer à la
campagne et bénéficié aussi d'un
environnement rural
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls freins
pour diversifier l'offre de produits et
augmenter la rentabilité de leur
entreprise
les maraîchers aimerait pouvoir à terme
vendre entre autres plus de et des
poulets de grain fait qu'il ya comme
cette idée doit être une ferme complexe
qui complète avec tout ce que ça
implique l'autosuffisance puis en même
temps il ya le point de vue légal qui
fait que ça nous met des bâtons dans les
roues car pour vendre des oeufs et du
poulet il faut détenir du quota un droit
de produire coûteux qui n'est pas bien
adaptés à la réalité des petites fermes
si on devait laisser plus de place aux
petites faire il faudrait évidemment
repenser aussi la transformation à la
distribution alimentaire
c'est extrêmement difficile pour elle de
trouver des abattoirs il ya beaucoup de
deux phénomènes où effectivement là les
filières se sont organisés encore une
fois plutôt pour produire en gros de
façon homogène pour alimenter les gros
circuits de distribution
sans mettre une croix sur les
exportations et les importations la
pandémie sera peut-être l'occasion
d'aller vers une agriculture davantage
façonné par nos propres besoins
alors que les frontières peuvent
rapidement se refermer être capable de
se nourrir d'abord soi-même apparaît
plus pertinent que jamais un très grand
manque de vent la libération des des
professions pas paraître trop
alimentaire depuis des années au québec
puis on boit en actifs personnels
soignants pour vous soigner on a besoin
de nourrir la 2 millions d'hectares
cultivables au québec à l'échelle de
l'amérique du nord c'est un grand jardin
on devrait en prendre soin vraiment